[拍手]
宜しくお願いします
まず皆さんに一つだけ質問をしたいことがあります
え
何かといいますと
毎日さんショップもし彼に職の方もいらっしゃるかもしれませんけれども
食事を取られている
でその1色1色
1日3食の方3色2色の方に食
すべての食事に満足されている方ってどれくらいいますか
ぜひ手を上げていただければ
[笑い]
やまーす名
本当に34人の形が今超上げられませんでした
しかし食事の時間っていうのは
結構大きな比率を占めているというところは言うまでもない
人間が一生のうちに食べる食事の回数というのは
80年の寿命
1日3食としたときに87000回以上
に及びます皆様はいろんな年齢層の方がいらっしゃると思いますがもうすでに半分以上
を割られている方もいれば
なんか嫌な言い方になりましたレーサーさあ
僕はこう見えてまだ27歳なので
あそこですかはい
なのでまぁまだもうちょっとあるかなという感じがするんですけれども
今日は何の話をしたいかというと
食べ物食べること食事
そういった行為に対して
ちょっといい未来とかちょっと幸せな食べ方とかすごい乗ってもう少し考えた方がいい
んじゃないかな
でもそんなところを今日はお話をさせていただければなというふうに思います
これは
いわゆるファストフードといわれるものたちです
僕ファーストフードを食べることもありますしこれを否定することは一切ないです
ただそのファストフードというものを8食べる時に皆さんどんな気持ちで食べますか
例えば疲れた会社の帰りにコンビニに
こうよってオーメン等を買って帰るとか
お昼ご飯忙しすぎてカップ麺しか食べれないとか何かしら
おいしいとか
あー食べれて良かったとかポジティブな感情を持って食べることってあんまり多くない
んじゃないかなと思う
でも本来食事ってそうあるべきじゃない本来食事は楽しみであり幸せであるはず
だというふうに僕は思っていますなので
食べることは作業ではないということです
で食べることは作業ではない
じゃないかって僕は思っているんですけれども今の経済合理性の中でこの資本主義の
社会の中で
できることっていうのは限られている時間も限られている
じゃあそこでどんなことが普段からできるんだろうな
そんな話をしたいというふうに思います
えっと僕の過去の写真なのですごく恥ずかしいんですけれども
と大学に在学中にですねこのきゅん草の写真や実はないんですが
え
和食の料理店で
調理をやってみました間違えてアルバイトで入ったみたいな感じなんですけど
コテコテの職人さんがいればいらっしゃるような食のところに
r バイト申し込もバイトしようと思ってですね申し込んだら
なんかこうすごいどやされるみたいなそういう意味ですね
ai 千島ちょっというところがでまでもそれは結局面白くて4年間続けてですね
あの
まあ最後は差し歯とかもですね全部を出してもらえるようになって料理の基礎的な
スキルを学ばしてもらったと
でその後ちょっと見る人が見たらわかってしまうんですけどの中央の写真ですねあの
飲食店の某大手チェーンのレストランというかまぁ
宮ホールというかもうすぐにわかっちゃうような感じになっちゃいますけど
フッフッフッとの8店舗運営方法るをやってました
でその後山梨県に移住をして空き家をリノベーションしたコミュニティーカフェ
レストランというところの運営をしていました
でそこで僕は山梨に移住をしてきっちの再定義というところに
注目をして
起業しましたなので二足のわらじしでその時はやっています
きっちの再定義って何かというといわゆる料理ということが今ものすごく作業化されて
いて
そのあんまり楽しくない面白くないできればやりたくない
なんかもうすぐマイナスな
ものになってしまって食べ物を作っているね美味しい食事を作ってみんなで食べると
いう場を作っているにも関わらず
料理ってすごくマイナスなイメージになっているなので者料理を使ってえっと普段の
生活はちょっと切り離して別のことに何が使えないかなというところでキッチンを
プラットフォームとして捉えて例えば親子でコア
ピザを作ってみたりとかですねこういうワークショップをやったりとか
まあ航空キングレシピって書いてあるんですけどもまぁ一風変わった餃子餃子を結果で
あるっていう
here に基づいてですね何かを積んでいればそれは餃子ぬふを餃子女性いう
ワークショップあっあってました
ここは大学の a 棟研究棟での写真ですけれども
まあ研究チームの皆のチームビルディングをしたりとかですね
料理って実はすごくいろんな可能性があるんだよっていうところ
まあやってましたと
ただそれで料理をツールにしていろんな課題解決だったりとか
ことをやっていくうちにですねこんなものたちに出会いました
形の悪い野菜たち
こういう野菜達って
僕もあんまり飲食店にずっと入ったんですけど見たことがあんまりなくて
スーパーにも並んでないしどこにあるか
これは青山のファーマーズマーケットで見つけたものなんですけれども
実は農家さんてものすごく多くの売れない野菜
食べれるのに売れない野菜っていうのをいっぱい持っているということに気付きます
ん
だから僕たちは料理をツールとしてフードロスあ
こういう野菜たちをどうやったら救えるか
っていうところをイベント的に青やなばまず負けとやってますそれがディスクスープっ
ていうイベントなんですけど
その
みんなで規格外野菜とか圃場背景になる野菜とかお料理をしてみんなで配って食べる
でそういうイベントを月1回
あまりのファーマーズマーケットでやってたら
フードロスの問題って
こういうところではやっぱり解決しないしみんな食べ物っていうところへの意識が
少しずつ
変わるためにはどうしたらいいんだろうっていうのを本気で考えるようになりました
なのでこのフードロスという問題一つをとっても食の世界ってものすごくダークサイド
存在している
なぜなら生産者から皆さんの口に運ばれるまでの間って
どれぐらいのプレーヤーがいるんだろう
なんかすごく大きいなその
合理化された仕組みの中に8我々は生きている
そうなったときに今食べてる物って誰が作ったもののかもよくわからない
そういう世界って
いろんなブラックボックス化が進んでいってるなというふうに思っています
今回フードロシュという話に特化をして話をしますが
日本の1年間のフードロス646万トンというふうに言われています
ただこれって最近ニュースとかいろんなメディアで取り上げられていてなんとなく数字
として見たことあるなぁと思ってる方もいらっしゃると思うんですけど
実は先ほど言った圃場排気とか規格外野菜とかそういったものの量は一切入ってない
です
これはあくまで流通に乗って段階以降のロスの分しか
換算されていない
だから
こういう感じですね
なんか一見普通に食べれそうだけど実はちょっとはれているとか傷がついちゃってると
かそういったものは一切市場に出ないですし
もう一つフードロスの
部分まあフードロスという観点から言うと実はメーカーさんとか
飲食店とかまさに僕自身もものすごい量のフードロスを実際にゴミ箱に捨てていた一人
です
飲食店に勤めていたとき
でデパ地下とかもそうですけどいわゆる
皆さんのメイン目の届かないところでものすごい量の食べ物は捨てられている
っていうことを僕は何知らないっていうことがものすごく気持ち悪いなと思ったんです
ね
でこの写真なんかまさにそのフードロスになりそうなものを
豚の飼料にしているエコフィードをつくっている
構造の写真なんですが
右上の写真とかですねまさに全然問題なく食べれそうなパンとかですね
右下の写真なんかも
調理すれば食べられるんじゃないっていうのはトウモロコシとかですね
平気でやっぱり捨てられているです
でフードロスという観点でもう一つと実は気づきづらい
課題が僕はあるなぁと思っているのがこのレシピ
という仕組みレシピって僕はすごく便利だと思うし
今後使っていける
今後もすごく重要なツールだというふうに思っていますが
レシピは
その反面ですね料理に正解を作ったと僕は思ってます
レシピどおりに料理をするということがものすごく夜中的に求められてきた
sp 通り料理してきれいなものを作るということが目的になっている
っていうことがものすごくフードロスを助長しているものであると
で実は某
レシピサイトをほてのですね
ところとかもですね
この現象に気づいているんですね
やっぱり自分たちは社会を良くしたけれども悪くした部分もある
っていうところに彼らも気づき始めている
なぜかというと
何かを作る時にこのキャベツを刻みますとかって書いてあっても
キャベツ1個かうって言ったらおそらく全部扱わないですよね
残ったものはやっぱりロスになっちゃうでもレシピに書いてあるから買う
その後家庭でのロスてどんどん増えていってしまう
もう一つ
僕がものすごく感銘を受けた
実際に沖縄で直接話しも聞いたんですが
ありそう+ご存知の方もいると思いますが
あっあと分シンプルフードという本を書いた人です
食べ物は本当に安いほうがいいんでしょうかっていう話をしてました
ん
食べもんって自分たちの体をつくっているものですよね
本当に安ければよかったんですか
安いとものがに価値があるんですかっていう話をありそう+はしてます
ん
経済合理性の中で何かしら
少し自分たちの身体と海の家とかを削ってはいないですか
っていう話をしています
僕はまさにそうだなーと思って
即の尊厳とか食べ物の勝ち
ってどこにあるんだろうっていうのを考え始めたきっかけ
まさにきっかけです
なんで僕自身はフードロスというものを少しでもなくせるムーブメントを作れないかと
か
8風泥数2
少しでも
皆さんに知ってもらうきっかけを作ったりとか a
活動を色々としています
ただこの問題で何が解決するんですかっていう一問一答形式で僕はないと思ってて
テクノロジーでも職別構造でも昆虫食でも
法整備社会運動
全て正解だし
すべてそれだけで成立しないと僕は思っています
そこで一つのアイディアです僕が提案スライダーは皆さん一人一人の普段から消費の
ストーリーを
を持ちましょうということです
何かを買うっていう行為に理由付けが今はなさすぎるんじゃないかなと
そこに何かがあるから食べようとかっていう話ではない
っていうのが僕の持論です
例えば牛乳に売り場とか
やっぱり皆さん後ろから撮りますよね
僕は取ると思うんですよ
ただ
牛乳を後ろから撮る理由って新しいちゃいいっていう話水じゃないじゃないか本当は
輸入から後ろを撮る人には後ろから撮る理由が本当に必要だと思うんですね
それは何かというと例えば自分の
生活環境島一人暮らしだと
そうなったら
輸入1本飲むのに1週間かかる
だったら後ろから撮ろういいと思うんですねただ自分のいえば4人家族ですと
6人家族ですなった時に牛乳は実は1日2日でみんな飲んじゃうんだよね
ってなった時に僕は手前からとるっていうのも
必要の通りなんじゃないかなと思っ
そんな所で何が本当に言いたいかというと自分にとって最も幸せな食べ方っていうのを
みなさん一人一人がしっかり考えなきゃいけない時代に僕はもう入ってきていると思っ
ています
食べ物を奪い合う時代っていうのは間違いなくこれからくる
で植物構造とかいろんなテクノロジーが解決してくれる部分もある
でもそうした一人一人が
変わらなければ
僕たちの生活が決して幸せにならないとか思っています
何よりも食べ方というのは
自分の意識とか消費行動にもつながってくる問題だというふうに思っています
ぜひ自分なりの食べ方っていうものを
発見していただければなというふうに思います
ありがとうございます
[拍手]